what up space fam golson here from anime
uproar back at it again to do an update
video for demon slayer about the manga
new movie and so on so make sure to stay
tuned for that
if you do enjoy the demonstrator videos
on this channel and want to keep them
coming the best you can do is hit that
like button really smash
it and share this video with any
demonstrator fans that you know
if you haven't be sure to subscribe if
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select
all or you will miss future demonstrator
videos and updates if you haven't yet
make this the day you subscribe and as
we wait for the second season of
demonstrator to drop
feel free to check out my growing demon
player playlist where we got videos
about the hashira
breath styles demon moons ranking all
those guys from weakest the strongest
and much more link to that is in the
description
and also check us out on the anime
uproar twitch also link in the
description
where we're streaming pretty much daily
talking about all the anime we cover
here and also just playing video games
and hanging out so again link to that
is in the description now without
further ado let's jump into it
so i will be getting into spoilers
eventually but first i want to discuss
the insane popularity of demon slayer
and put it into perspective
as a challenge made so many demonstrator
videos and if some of you actually watch
like every single one in the
demonstrator playlist
props to you thank you so much because
there are so many there but anyways
i feel like we need to acknowledge how
awesome it
is that a series we love so much has
shocked the world with the level of
popularity it's reached
before we get to the movie and before
the movie even dropped the demonstrator
manga was seeing insane numbers of sales
for the year 2019 demonstrator outsold
one piece and considering how many
volumes one piece has out
the number is approaching 100 by the way
and the volumes demonstrator has out the
22nd just dropped that's insane to think
about before that
one piece had an 11 year reign as number
one in 2019 demonstrators sold around 12
million
and one piece around 10 million
according to oricon
however demonstrator did even better
this year in 2020 for manga sales
for the first half of 2020 from november
18th 2019
to may 17 2020 and yeah they start
counting in 2019 rather than
2020. that's just how they do it but in
the first half
demonstrators sold an unbelievable 45
297 63333 manga
compared to second place one piece which
sold less than 5 million copies in the
same time period
and in half a year demonstrator almost
multiplied its own
awesome 2019 numbers by four
with the movie dropping for the week of
october 19th to 25th
all of demon slayer's 22 volumes held
the top 22 spots
on oricon's weekly top 30 selling manga
chart which is a new record
the first time that's happened for any
manga series
is one more volume the final one set to
release
this year and that's sure to shoot up
the sales for demonstrator
even more from what i can tell one
piece's best year for sales
at the peak of its popularity was in
2011 when the sales were
approaching 40 million volumes sold in
one full year so beating that number
in the first half of a year and setting
the new all-time record is
mind-blowing to say the least we should
keep that in mind that in regards to
manga history this is a historical year
we are living through right now
according to oricon overall the
demonstrator physical sales
passed 90.5 million and if we count
digital
that's over 100 million the sky's the
limit
at this point for what demon slayer will
hit this year specifically since the
movie is popping off
breaking its own record in the box
office and the last volume is still to
be released as well
this is very exciting stuff this is kind
of like if drake dropped an album with
22 songs and the top 22 most popular
songs on the radio
were all the songs from that album it's
absolutely crazy
i mean we knew when famous gamer
streamers
start tweeting about specific episodes
of an anime and saying it's their
favorite
we've reached a pretty insane level of
popularity
but i think i've explained to an extent
the demon sarah manga numbers and why
exactly they are so shocking because
it's straight up making manga history
before our eyes
of course one piece it has to be said is
still way ahead in overall sales than
demon slayer
with over 470 million overall copies
sold
but considering how many less volumes of
demonstrator there are
and how it's been out for a much shorter
period of time than one piece
this doesn't take away from demon
slayer's insane record-breaking
accomplishments at all
unfortunately the manga did end but at
least we did get that
awesome bonus than goku chapter that i
covered recently on the channel link to
that video is in the description as well
now let's get to the demon slayer movie
which if you somehow still don't know
is canon meaning that it covers the next
part of the manga
right where season 1 left off it's not
just some
side story that can't change any of the
rules
it is legit what happens next so that
pretty much forces any people who want
to continue the story in anime form to
watch it
clearly a smart move as we're about to
see now we gotta keep in mind that this
movie was released on october 16th
during the pandemic
most people you ask they aren't even
down to go to the movie theaters yet
period and still somehow demon slayer
has taken japan by storm
not only did it do well which would be
surprising in and of itself under these
circumstances
it had the best ever opening weekend in
japanese cinema history in 17 days
it grossed more than 150 million us
dollars
and that's only counting japan because
it hasn't been released internationally
yet
as you probably know with this in just a
17 day period it became the 10th
highest grossing movie in japanese box
office history
not talking about anime films or even
just japanese films
but movies in general in just 17 days
and while the pandemic is going on these
are truly mind-boggling numbers
i mean sure we could have expected the
demonstrator movie to be popular but
this popular
in these times that's just shocking once
again
we are witnessing history in the making
and this isn't just a big win for
demonstra fans
it's also a big win for anime series in
general the highest grossing one piece
film during its entire run in japan
made about 66 million usd and
demonstrator made 150 million in less
than two and a half weeks
i mean in 17 days it passed the entire
run of weathering with you
which was the biggest film of japan in
2019
and those were pre-pandemic times and
honestly it will probably just keep
marching straight up through the top 10
earning films in japan list
which includes films like titanic frozen
harry potter spirited away your name and
so on and it might
actually grab that number one spot
during these
social distancing times it's truly
amazing stuff the movie should be
launching in the us and canada in early
2021
so let me know in the comments if you're
planning to watch it or if you're gonna
wait until things seem a bit safer
i will update you guys when we know more
about when the movie is dropping exactly
so make sure you're subscribed and have
that notification bell pressed
we do know exactly what the movie will
be covering
and i'm gonna get into that now so
here's your spoiler warning three
two one and we're back without the
people scared of spoilers
so if you're a manga fan you'll know
what comes after season one and
empowered
lower moon one enmu takes on our guys on
the demon train
earlier on i wasn't sure where the film
would cut out exactly
before or after rain goku and upper moon
three axis fight
i thought maybe it would end with akuza
showing up
and then there would be a lot of hype
for the next season but from what i
gather
we will actually see the full epic fight
and
see then goku's death as well and that
is one of my favorite battles in demon
slayer so i totally understand
why there's so much hype around the
movie if you haven't read ahead in the
manga
demon series just gonna get better after
season one
so to see all of that animated will be
absolutely amazing
and clearly it should all get animated
looking at this level of popularity
but yeah there it is everything we know
so far about the
insane record-breaking success of the
demonstrator manga
and the demonstrator movie and boy i
love seeing anime films especially films
based off of anime
series beating out some of the most
popular live-action films of all time
it's an exciting time for us anime fans
since anime really seems to be taking
over
since i've been around i've seen more
and more anime become more and more
mainstream but i can't say i expected a
shonen anime movie
to be on its way to becoming the number
one top grossing
film in japanese box office history
during these of all times and it's well
on its way to beating the top grossing
hollywood movie of 2020 which was bad
boys for life which had a domestic gross
of about 205 million dollars but anyways
if you did enjoy this video and want to
keep seeing demon sare videos on this
channel you know what to do
make sure to hit and really smash
that like button to let me know and to
share this video with any demonstrator
fans that you know
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select all or you will miss
future demonstrator videos
if you haven't yet make this the day you
subscribe a lot more demonstrate content
is on its way especially when we start
getting more and more info and more and
more seasons
so i'm super excited for that and as we
wait for that second season of
demonstrator to drop
feel free to check out my growing demon
slayer playlist where we got videos
about the hashira
breath styles demon moons and much much
more
link to that is in the description and
i'll also add a link to the anime upper
twitch make sure to check that out and
come hang out we're on there pretty much
daily
talking about the anime we cover on this
channel
and also just playing games and hanging
out so once again that link is
in the description and i especially want
to thank the patron squad over on
patreon and here on youtube who helped
make videos like this one possible
first and foremost i want to thank the
patron of legend the one acknowledged by
lord twigo himself alpha sigma
and are the one-tier patrons the ones
who stand atop all clans
in grata the world acquire respect liam
thompson pate hepa
red-haired raven emperor otaku thomas
jones and spidey life chanel
and are pro heroes to your patrons the
one and only gilgamesh
who's the current most donated overall
champion of the world
steelers angel cruz anatoly kazotsky
cricket xp
joe stanton rathu and dora very gucci
jessica kayla fond alicia actor hinokami
and water bonnie parks florian joanne
garcia
deadly saint high school dxd 73 baked
buddhist
matthew cruz and anthony schreiber thank
you all
so much if you enjoy our work you can
support more of it by going over to
patreon.com animeopro and becoming a
patron today for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patron only discord where we talk about
anime life and of course
thank memes so check out patreon.com
anime uproar
link in the description if you're
interested you can also join the youtube
channel by clicking that blue join
button next to the subscribe button
that you've hopefully already destroyed
so yeah you can support more content now
if you prefer
whichever way to support us you will get
the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you